well the first full week of full-time
distance education is in the books for
the clark county school district
but as 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond shows us some students are
noticing a physical side effect
from that additional screen time
staring at a computer for hours he's on
steady from eight in the morning
till two in the afternoon amy moore
watches her son brody attend his third
grade ccsd classes online
my son is pretty good with computers but
soon noticed a distressing side effect
from the
extended screen time he cries in the
afternoon he's got such a bad headache
by the end of the day
possibly the result of digital eye
strain a growing concern among other
parents in the valley during distance
education
just within the first week i'd say
there's been an uptick of
you know 20 percent of visits just for
digital eye strain excess blinking
eye rubbing dr naomi warner is a
pediatric ophthalmologist
she says screen time can be a risk to
eyes
from the standpoint of possibly inducing
nearsightedness or causing hiv glasses
sooner than later
to prevent the negative side effects of
extended screen time dr warner
recommends children getting outside for
an hour or two
and following the 20 20 20 rule every 20
minutes you're on a screen you should
take about a 20 second break
look somewhere far away like 20 feet
away blink your eyes a few times
refresh everything and then come right
back to it as for glasses that block
blue light
she calls them the buzzword these days
it doesn't hurt to try it
but i don't recommend them right now
because i don't think it's uh
there's no good research behind it
stating that yeah they're going to help
prevent headaches or eye strain so we
ordered some
blue light blocking glasses and are
hoping that that helps more
considering different options to ease
her son's eyes
kristen drummond 8 news now dehydration
and a lack of sleep can also cause
headaches but it's encouraged children
get eye exams if they are having any eye
troubles
or any side effects from that additional
screen time